[Music]
behold the greatest collection of Marvel
Studios costumes and props ever
assembled in the same place and all of
which are from characters you'll see
again in phase 4 right here at d23 Expo
2019 hello
Marvel fans I'm Ryan puñado say K agent
M and I am here at the Marvel Studios
booth it's so cool so big everything
here at d23 Expo 2019 is awesome they
got stuff to see to do to get your hands
on my favorite thing though for all the
costumes and props we got to go check
them out right now I told you these are
so cool we have Scarlet Witch Doctor
Strange Valkyrie and Thor and it has
maybe my favorite prop in all the MCU
Stormbreaker you guys wanted Loki we've
got Loki plus of course some amazing
props including the tesseract including
Falcons wings including Bucky's
vibranium arm and of course Hawk eyes
bow arrows and other weaponry I know
we're all excited for Marvel Studios
Black Widow in 2020 but before we get
there we got to look back at some of the
most iconic looks for one of the MCS
greatest heroes here at d23 expo 2019 we
were super lucky to get inside the
Marvel Studios pavilion early before the
crowds came in and get really hyped for
this because there's gonna be signings
there's gonna be panels there's gonna be
trivia there's nothing strange about it
Marvel Studios brought their magic to
d23 Expo 2019 I'm Ryan and this is
Marvel your universe